alors oui ça que je devais pas oublié
c'était de récupérer les carottes
sauvages
hu qu'est ce que vous faites là vous
[Musique]
vous attendez le deuxième épisode sur
les zombies
ah non mais attendez c'est pas possible
ça m'a vachement temps je vous ai dit il
n'est pas prêt l'épisode
quoi le décor oui oui ici le décor il
est un peu chamboulée ça c'est parce que
je suis en train de déménager
c'est la dernière fois vous le voyez
d'ailleurs le décor quoi voulez que ça
c'est une dernière vidéo dans ce décor
pour en profiter ouais ok je veux bien
mais sur quoi du coup sur norbert elias
norbert elias
c'est vrai que je voulais présenter la
dernière vidéo mais qu' il reste des
choses à en dire bon c'est parti mais
pour ça il va falloir un nouveau format
on est parti
[Musique]
et
alors bienvenue dans sociaux classiques
une émission où je vais revenir sur les
auteurs classiques de la sociologie en
étudiant tout ou une partie de leur
travail quand ça prend trop de temps et
en présentant voilà des auteurs que
j'estime comme un peu incontournables et
aujourd'hui on revient sur norbert elias
[Musique]
norbert elias alors j'en ai parlé dans
ma dernière vidéo que je vous invite à
consulter
principalement connu pour sa thèse du
processus de civilisation on va revenir
un petit peu plus en détails sur sa vie
et sur la totalité de son travail
alors comme je voulais vie c'est un
sociologue allemand mais ce qui est
intéressant avec lui c'est qu'il fait
vraiment figure de transition dans la
sociologie contemporaine
pourquoi une figure de transition va
tout d'abord parce que il est né à la
fin du 19e siècle en 1897
on sent très clairement aux
contemporains des grands sociologues
comme dürckheim webber puis alvac marcel
mauss et cetera et de fait c'est
vraiment leurs contemporains son
directeur de thèse c'est alfred waeber
c'est un sociologue économiste qui est
le frère de matt webber qui est quand
même un petit peu plus connus et en 1930
il devient l'assistant de karl mannheim
qui est un des fondateurs de l'école de
francfort alors j'ai pas forcément prévu
de parler l'école de francfort pour
l'instant mais si vous voulez en savoir
un peu plus je vous invite à consulter
la chaîne politiken qui en parlent
vraiment très bien mais après ce qui va
être intéressant avec elias c'est que il
traverse en fait tout xxème siècle
puisqu'il meurt en 1990 ce qui en fait
en fait le contemporain de tous les
sociologues contemporain maintenant pour
prendre un exemple un sociologue
français actuel est quand même assez
connu françois de singly s'appuie assez
directement sur les travaux des liasses
pour présenter ses propres théories
alors il vient juste de prendre sa
retraite mais je trouve que j'assistais
une de ses conférences à la sorbonne
mercredi dernier et que ce qu'il a fait
c'est qu'il est vraiment partie de la
définition de l'individu donné par elias
pour ensuite développer son propre
raisonnement donc on voit que elias mine
de rien il est quand même assez actuelle
même dans les penseurs très contemporain
de la sociologie
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a tant apporté à
la sociologie pourquoi son considère
comme une figure aussi importante j'ai
commencé par l'intéressé un de ses
textes un petit peu plus tardif puisque
voilà paru
après sa mort en 1991 et qui s'appelle
la société des individus
je vous le montre alors quand je dis un
texte un petit peu tardif en fait le
livre est composé de trois parties les
premières datant des années 30 et les
dernières datant des années 80 donc en
fait ça fait c'est une espèce de
patchwork mais qui a quand même à
l'unité et il essaye de réfléchir un
petit peu à la société dans son ensemble
lorsqu'il essayait de faire dans ce
livre là c'est qu'il essaye de dépasser
en fait l'opposition traditionnelle
qu'on met entre la société et les
individus puisqu'en fait souvent une des
questions qu'on se pose c'est qu'est-ce
qui vient en premier la société où les
individus puisque en fait la société
elles influencent les individus c'est à
dire que 20 pendant tout le processus de
socialisation
on va incorporer des normes et des
valeurs et du coup la société nous
influence oui mais bon la société elle
est quand même composé d'individus
donc c'est tous ces individus qui vont
influencer la société et du coup il ya
toujours un peu une question un peu
fondamentale en sociologie de posture en
fait vous avez peu de savoir si on se
place du point de vue de la société et
là c'est plutôt les sociologues aux
listes en avait déjà parlé ou si on se
place plutôt du point de vue des
individus mais là ce sera plutôt les
sociologues individualisme du coup le
titre même du bouquin montre bien ce
qu'il veut faire à la société des
individus montre bien qu'il veut
réunifier la notion de société la notion
d'individu et en fait ce que fait elias
et dire il faut arrêter de se poser
cette question faut arrêter en fait
d'opposer l'individu et la société comme
si on pouvait les dissocier
en fait ce qui compte c'est que on peut
jamais dire un individu parce qu'un
individu il est jamais tout seul un
individu s'il est toujours inséré dans
un réseau d'inter relation on est
toujours intégré dans un réseau d'un tas
relations au sein de la société
et ça c'est une notion qui va vraiment
mettre en place dans la troisième partie
de cet ouvrage là qui sort en 1989 et
qui s'appelle les transformations de
l'equilibre nous jeu est en fait ce qui
monte c'est vraiment que au fur et à
mesure de l'histoire on a toujours été
porté tous les humains par en fait à
chercher un équilibre entre le nous et
le je et le nous qui représenterait la
société mais pas la société dans son
ensemble la société en tant que inter
relation est le jeu le jeu qui
représente mon individualité et ce qu'il
dit mais là pour le coup il n'est pas du
tout le seul à le dire c'est que on vit
aujourd'hui dans des sociétés de plus en
plus individualiste j'en reparlerai
d'individualisme et plus tard et ça sera
du commandes pour lui ça se traduit par
une nouvelle peau des rations dans notre
identité du nous et du jeu c'est à dire
une importance plus grande du jeu et une
importance - grandes dunes où il ya
plein d'exemples de ça aujourd'hui on se
définit beaucoup moins par nos parents
le new familiale au moins important
qu'avant
avant quand ton père te disais moi je
suis menuisier et tu seras menuisier tu
reprends dans la sphère familiale
on ne faisait pas l'histoire de la même
façon quand il de notaire etc
aujourd'hui maintenant qu'on vit dans
une société plus individualiste on
accorde une plus grande importance à ce
jeu est pour émerger ce jeu il a besoin
de se défaire d'une familiale est là et
ce qui est important de remarquer il
faut pas croire que le jeu il est en
coupure avec le reste de la société il
est quand coupure totale avec les nous
parce que des nous y en a plusieurs
et si on se coupe d'une ou familiale en
fait on va se rapprocher d'autres nous
d'une ou amicaux une des noues qu'on va
rencontrer dans le monde du travail etc
etc et en fait s'il constate c'est qu'il
ya une multiplication de différent nous
et du coup ça sert à rien d'opposer
individus et sociétés parce qu'en fait
le jeu
eux c'est déjà d'une ou encore port et
c'est à dire que pendant tout le
processus de socialisation ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on apprend les valeurs de notre
société on a on apprend les normes on
apprend les valeurs que nous apprennent
aux parents mais que nous apprennent
aussi toutes les autres instances de
socialisation à la famille les médias le
travail et tout ça ça va nous faire
incorporé en fait des choses qui sont
pas nous des choses qui viennent de la
société mais qu'on va utiliser pour se
définir notre propre identité du coup
dans la définition même de notre propre
identité à nous donc du coup le jeu est
bien là d'une ou encore port ayez de la
société incorporée donc en fait ça sert
à rien d'opposer l'individu et la
société parce que l'individu
il est déjà de la société incorporée est
ce qu'il va être très intéressant du
coup c'est que en fait il va avoir une
échelle d' analyse qui est pas du tout
l'échelle qu'on avait l'habitude de voir
en sociologie entre l'échelle au lycée
l'échelle d'un djihadiste parce qu'il va
se placer à une échelle qu'on appelle
l'échelle mezzo dit regarde pas
l'individu tout seuls n'y a pas la
société dans son ensemble et il va
regarder des échelles maison et ça c'est
parce qu'en fait il a une formation de
psychologue aussi à la fois et en fait
il va réunifier la sociologie de l'état
devait beurre avec la psychologie de
freud et va essayer de faire tenir
ensemble en fait les changements aux
notaires un haut niveau de l'état au
niveau du pouvoir au niveau de la
société et les changements
psychologiques des personnes pour le
dire avec des termes scientifiques il
arrive à faire tenir ensemble une
analyse macro sociologique des
populations et de l'état et une analyse
micro sociologique de l'individu et que
ses pulsions notamment et ça c'est ce
que j'avais commencé un petit peu a
développé dans ma vidéo sur les zombies
c'est ce qui montre à travers ce qu'il
appelle le processus de civilisation
donc ça c'est dans ce bouquin la la
civilisation des moeurs alors juste une
parenthèse au cas où des puristes des
éditions originales des liasses se
cacheraient parmi vous on sait jamais
parce que entre les ouvrages écrits en
trois fois sur 60 ans et ceux qui ne
sont pas publiées à cause de l'allemagne
nazie
les publications des liasses c'est un
peu le bordel donc le processus de
civilisation ou en vo über den process
des civilisations sociaux génie steinen
il paraît en 1939
l'oeuvre passe alors relativement
inaperçu et du fait d origine juive de
son auteur et du fait qu'être juif en
1939 en allemane c'était pas forcément
la louve rage sortira d'oubli grâce à sa
réédition allemand de 1969 qui sort un
gros succès et c'est donc après ça qu'il
sera traduit et édité en france le livre
original était composé de deux parties
qui seront publiés séparément en france
d'abord la civilisation des moeurs qui
sort en 1974 qui correspond à la partie
allemande wallander est ensuite la
dynamique de l'occident en 1975 qui
correspond à la partie allemande van
lommel et mov civilisation
ce qui ne sonne pas du tout comme un
manuel d'utilisation destinées à
détruire toute vie sur terre c'est donc
dans ce bouquin lac il explique que
depuis presque toujours mais lui il
commence vraiment à l'étudier depuis la
renaissance
la société connaît un phénomène de
pacification des moeurs ce qu'il appelle
le processus de civilisation qui se
caractérise à la fois par le fait que
l'on vit dans des sociétés de moins en
moins violentes
typiquement aujourd'hui c'est tout à
fait normal de laisser moisir à
l'intérieur de nous n'aurons coeur non
exprimés qu'on essaiera d'exorciser
pendant trente ans de psychiatrie mais
on a tendance à ne plus cramer la maison
de notre voisin au moindre désagrément
attention attention il va arriver un
moment il ya des grands shows that he a
flambé pour la peur de demander d'où ça
vient et ce processus de civilisation va
aussi de pair avec le fait que nos
sociétés se sont dotés de pouvoirs
juridiques et étatique de plus en plus
puissants et centralisée et moi qu'est
ce que vous voulez que [ __ ] de vos
conneries
une heure et demi que je m'interdis la
sérénade et mon année mais chiant mais
poulmaire delà vous avez de quoi vous en
payer 150 des ânes avec ça alors
maintenant vous allez me [ __ ] le camp
aubry voit les débuts et je suis désolé
sans vouloir critiquer et si on est
plutôt censé faire office d'arbitré
veuille ou non mais je sais j'ai remis
train peu sec c'est parce que en même
temps ça
pour ça c'est ce que j'ai présenté dans
ma dernière vidéo mais concrètement
comment ça se met en place pourquoi les
gens commencent à reconnaître plus en
plus leurs pulsions pourquoi on va vers
plus de deux contrôles et surtout quel
rapport avec la centralisation de l'état
et le monopole de la violence légitime
alors déjà pour que des changements dans
les règles de la convenance se met en
place
il faut un certain nombre de choses et
déjà ce qu'il faut basse et de la
pression sociale
la pression sociale ça veut dire qu'il
faut que les gens qui vous observent et
qui vous disent ben ça c'est pas bien il
faut pas le faire
[Musique]
ou qui au contraire vous récompense
qu'on vous fait quelque chose de bien
déjà on voit qu'il faut des
interdépendances entre les gens font que
les gens soient en relation avec les
autres il faut qu'ils aient besoin de
respecter cette étiquette
et du coup c'est par le biais de cette
pression réciproque que petit à petit on
finit par accepter de nouvelles règles
ont fini par les intériorisé nous-mêmes
et puis que finalement elles nous
paraissent naturelles ça c'est la
dernière phase de l'intériorisation et
pour que les individus puissent faire
pression les uns sur les autres
il faut qu'ils soient en relation et ce
qui va se passer tout au long de ce
processus de civilisation mais c'est
qu'en fait
l'interdépendance entre les gens va
considérablement augmenter
elias il montre que ces nouvelles règles
de la société
elles vont se diffuser dans toute la
population deux étapes
première étape dans la noblesse via le
phénomène de curial isation et ouais je
me l'a pu avec des mots compliqués la
curial isation c'est simplement le fait
que les nobles commence à s'organiser
autour du roi dans une assemblée qu'on
appelle la cour
alors oui j'ai déjà parlé de ça dans la
première vidéo mais pourquoi c'est
important
en quoi le fait que des nobles se
mettent à s'organiser autour du roi est
restée avec lui en permanence ça va
changer les règles de vie et de
comportement et l'intériorisation des
pulsions de toute la population alors
pour comprendre ça il faut comprendre un
peu comment s'organiser la france avant
le 16e siècle c'est-à-dire avant la
curial isation alors déjà ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'à cette époque là il n'y
a pas un pouvoir super centralisée avec
un roi au pouvoir absolu et divin même
s'ils vont il ya déjà une royauté de
droit divin
mais ce n'est pas l'image qu'on a le
plus souvent aujourd'hui quand on pense
au roi de france
non en fait le pouvoir il est divisé
entre les différents seigneurs féodaux
et en fait ces seigneurs féodaux cd m
sans partage qui gouvernent leurs terres
et les gens qui vivent en rendant
quasiment aucun compte à personne
vraiment ces gens là ils kiffent se
faire la guerre c'est vraiment leur
raison de vivre un tout leur éducation
repose sur les valeurs guerrières veut
dire pour être un homme faut savoir se
battre il faut aller brûler le château
de ton voisin pour montrer qu'on a une
grosse quand je veux dire vraiment la
guerre est juste en mode de régulation
normale entre eux ces différents
seigneurs je serai inflexible ça dure
trois jours on va discuter méthode
technologies les dernières tactiques les
dernières tactiques pour pulvériser son
voisin c'est très enrichissant
parce que votre balle merdique c'est
enrichissant quatre jours avoir ligoté
des [ __ ]
dépenser samedi les nerfs et le pouvoir
royal à cette époque qu'il est assez
faible en fait ce qui fait que les
seigneurs de guerre ils sont assez
indépendant et finalement ils sont quand
même pas mal l'indiscipliné autant du
point de vue du pouvoir du roi auquel
ils doivent normalement respect mais
aussi du point de vue de l'église qui a
finalement pas vraiment imposé de règles
très strictes
à cette époque là et on voit vraiment là
se mettre en place une réelle volonté de
pacification de la part du pouvoir royal
dire que c'est louis xiv qu'il tient à
ce que tous ces courtisans soit toujours
autour de lui placer sous son contrôle
de façon à pouvoir leur imposer des
façons d'être des façons de faire des
habitus très stricte mais aussi il va
leur retirer l'autorisation de porter
les armes déposent les armes et on
pourra régler cette histoire d'une autre
ils leur retire aussi la permission de
se faire des guerres privé juste une
petite parenthèse en fait c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé au japon
en 1870 au moment de la restauration de
l'armée angie
parce qu'en fait un les seigneurs de
guerre française s'est quasiment des
samouraïs c'est quasiment la même
fonction et pareil les samouraïs c'est
ce qui allait le droit de porter des
armes qui avaient la coiffure
traditionnelle et au moment où l'emploi
la restauration meiji fait qu' il veut
désarmer pacifié et aller vers plus de
modernité etc
ben il va retirer aux samouraïs le droit
de porter les armes et ça va donner lieu
à des révoltes des samouraïs notamment
la bataille de cette sous mac est la
plus connue et qui sont en fait les
événements qui sont racontés dans le
film le dernier samouraï avec tom cruise
voilà je sais pas c'est une information
que je trouve intéressant de partager et
du coup maintenant ça c'est la première
étape
on comprend en quoi le fait d'avoir un
état plus fort et plus centralisée ça
marche avec le fait d'avoir des nobles
plus pacifié moins agressif et du coup
bien plus d'intériorisation des pulsions
donc là ce processus de civilisation qui
va vers de plus en plus de retenue et de
moins en moins de violence au cours du
temps on comprend bien en quoi il est
lié à la fois au niveau macro deux états
et au niveau des individus pour les
nobles mais là ça ne satisfait pas
complètement parce que les nobles ça
représente à peu près 3% de la
population
donc on comprend pas trop en quoi le
fait que les nobles eux soit bien
pacifié qui récitent des poèmes qu'ils
arrêtent de se faire la guerre qu'ils
soient plus violents et cetera et cetera
ça a vraiment un rapport avec le fait
que l'ensemble de la population
va commencer à adopter ces mêmes règles
c'est même nom mais certaines valeurs on
est d'accord que c'est pas mécanique et
c'est là qu'on va passer à la deuxième
étape du raisonnement des liasses est là
pour choisi va avoir plusieurs raisons
d'adopter de plus d'auto contrôle et de
réfréner ses pulsions
alors déjà la première raison qu'on peut
sembler qui peut sembler évidentes ces
limitations de la noblesse
oui parce qu'en fait il ya quand même
des contacts entre la noblesse et la
haute bourgeoisie mais ce serait trop
facile d'expliquer tout la diffusion
simplement par imitation de la noblesse
donc non il ya aussi d'autres choses et
c'est autre chose ça va être l'évolution
de la sphère économique
et oui c'est le développement du marché
de l'économie capitaliste qui va pousser
les hommes à ce civilisationnel
c'est pas beau ça civilisationnel visa
risée et 10 as you nous est bref
effectivement c'est le développement de
la sphère marchande qui va permettre
l'émergence de ce qu'on a appelé la
société civile alors fait on va assister
à ce qu'on appelle une judiciarisation
des rapports sociaux pour être ce qui se
passe c'est qu'avec le développement de
l'activité va y avoir de plus en plus
d'activités marchande
ok ça c'est cool mais quand il ya de
plus en plus d'activités marchande ça
veut dire qu on est aussi en relation
avec de plus en plus de monde quand on
est en relation avec quelqu'un qu'on
connaît très bien parce que c'est son
frère ou son père ou son beau-frère et
c'est ok on travaille ensemble n'y a pas
de problème on est basée sur la
confiance tu vois mais quand on commence
à élargir sa sphère à des gens qu'on
connaît pas on les connaît pas et on
peut pas leur faire confiance
donc du coup il faut inventer des trucs
pour pouvoir quand même réussir à
commercer avec des gens qu'on connaît
pas et ça ça fait qu'il va y avoir de
plus en plus de contrats entre les
personnes et du coup c'est le
développement économique qui va faire
qu'il ya de plus en plus de relations
entre les gens de plus en plus de
relation contractuelle et que du coup
les gens vont devoir aussi de plus en
plus respecté le droit parce que c'est
pas tout de réussir à faire des contrats
mais il faut aussi avoir confiance en
une institution qui serait capable de
faire appliquer le droit
et du coup encore une fois on voit qu'il
ya une interdépendance entre le
processus psychologique et intellectuel
de pacification et d'intériorisation des
pulsions et le développement d'un état
ou d'un pouvoir judiciaire fort parce
que pour qu'on mette en place des
contrats il faut qu'il ya pouvoir
judiciaire et qu'on est aussi confiance
en pouvoir étatique qui soit capable de
faire appliquer la loi
et là on en revient au monopole de la
violence légitime c'est-à-dire que
l'état c'est le seul cas le droit de
faire usage de la violence et donc de
faire appliquer la loi
et encore une fois du coup le processus
de civilisation une avance parce que les
gens se font pression les uns sur les
autres mutuellement on en relation avec
le plus en plus de gens 1
de fait du développement de la sphère
économique il faut respecter une
étiquette dans de plus en plus de
situations parce qu'on se permet pas
avec des étrangers des choses qu'on se
permettait en famille et du coup on a
plus en plus l'habitude d'appliquer
certains comportements et qu'on va finir
par intérioriser et c'est qu'on va
transmettre ensuite nos enfants etc
et c'est comme ça que se diffuser se
développe ce processus de civilisation
de pacification d'intériorisation des
pulsions et mais par contre c'est long
ça se met en place du xvième siècle et
ça continue encore une autre jour on est
toujours encore en train de continuer à
se pacifier intériorisé les pulsions et
ses acteurs alors ouais donc donc là
dans le phénomène que je viens d'écrire
on n'a pas encore touché toute la
population on est surtout dans la
bourgeoisie puisque c'est elle qui est
marchande et c'est elle qui a vraiment
affaire avec beaucoup de gens et en
comprend bien comment à partir de la
bourgeoisie là il ya des phénomènes
d'interactions et d'imitations qui vont
rentrer en jeu avec tout le reste de la
société et qui vont faire que petit à
petit le modèle va finir par se diffuser
et donc là c'est vraiment la deuxième
étape de comment se diffuse ce processus
de civilisation à toute la population
donc voilà d'après elias c'est comme ça
que se propage le processus de
civilisation en articulant à la fois le
côté macro de la centralisation de
l'état et l'intériorisation micro des
pulsions personnel et c'est pour ça
qu'on vit aujourd'hui dans la société la
moins violente de l'histoire parce que
nos affects nos sensibilités nos
habitudes mais aussi nos organisations
étatiques vont dans ce sens depuis
plusieurs siècles et diot alors une fin
d'épisode un petit peu abrupte en fait
j'ai encore plein de trucs à vous dire
sur elias a notamment je voulais
développer un de ses ouvrages dans un
peu plus tardif où il met en pratique sa
théorie du processus de civilisation au
regard non plus précisément l'exemple du
sport les en fait je me suis aperçu que
ce bouquin était suffisamment
intéressant pour faire un épisode à part
entière et que cette vidéo est déjà bien
assez longue
donc je vous retrouve très vite pour la
2e partie de cet épisode qui parlera de
sport et civilisations
du coup bas des bisous à tous a très
vite je veux une nouvelle bonne fête
d'anniversaire que la force soit avec
vous
on n'oublie pas de s'abonner il m en
poussant l'air si cet épisode vous a plu
et si vous voulez me rejoindre sur
facebook ou regarder les épisodes
précédents c'est par ici que ça se passe
prenez soin de vous à la prochaine ciao
[Musique]